le procès du naufrage de l'erika est le
premier en france d'une catastrophe
écologique majeure le tribunal
correctionnel de paris à quatre mois
pour établir les responsabilités
après sept ans d'enquêté quinze
personnes morales et physiques ont été
renvoyés devant la justice pour
pollution en décembre 99 ce bateau avait
pris la mer en pleine tempête
avec trente mille tonnes de pétrole à
son bord véronique gens alors albert au
cinéma le kent une centaine d'avocats
quinze prévenus 70 parties civiles et
pour le premier jour du procès du
naufrage de l'erika
trois candidats à l'élection
présidentielle dans les couloirs du
palais de justice
dominique voynet ministre de
l'environnement au moment de la
catastrophe mais aussi corinne lepage
avocate de plusieurs communes et
philippe de villiers ont fait entendre
leur voix avant l'audience
je suis là pour défendre un département
qui a été souillé une côte atlantique
étaient blessés et aussi pour pour
penser à l'avenir parce que depuis que
nous parlons il ya déjà deux bateaux
poubelles qui sont passés sur le rail
d'ouessant
j'en attends que la justice passe
et aussi que le tout soit élevé non pas
par plaisir de faire payer mais parce
que nous vivons dans un monde économique
où seuls comptent malheureusement la
finance et il faut que polluer les
coudes ça coûte très cher sinon ça
continuera 12 décembre 99 l'erika se
casse en deux libérant 20 mille tonnes
de fuel bilan 400 km de côtes souillées
et plus de cent cinquante mille oiseaux
mazoutés
le préjudice infligé à l'économie
bretonne est évalué à plus d'un milliard
d'euros un grand absent à l'audience
aujourd'hui le capitaine indien du
navire filmé lors de son arrestation
en revanche l'ancien propriétaire un
golden boy italien giuseppe savarese
s'est présentée il est soupçonné d'avoir
violé délibérément les règles de
sécurité
quant au groupe total l'affréteur de
l'erika son système de défense n'a pas
varié depuis sept ans la compagnie prend
des navires qui sont certifiés il dit
le certificat en l'espèce il les avait
tous il était fort bien côté par les
ports il veut d'être passée en grande
visite case mois plutôt conséquent il
n'y avait aucune raison qu'il ne soit
pas affréter le procès devrait expliquer
pourquoi l'erika un bateau à une seule
coque vieux de 25 ans a pris la mer en
pleine tempête malgré plusieurs
inspections ayant signalé de grave
traces de corrosion